it was a long awaited speech from
president macron outlining how his
presidency will rally against the
political Islam we can advance an
incredible way to fight against a
political ideology this Islamist
separatism which is incompatible with
freedom and equality incompatible with
the indivisibility of the Republic and
the necessary unity of the nation first
in the firing line is foreign
interference makan has vowed to end a
program that allows countries such as
Algeria and Turkey to send Imams and
teachers here to provide services
without supervision
this scheme in place since the 1970s
allows those foreigners to provide
language and cultural lessons to help
children maintain a link with their
country of origin around some 80,000
children attend these classes every year
I'm not comfortable with the idea of
having women and men in schools of the
Republic who can teach without the
education system exercising their
slightest control and we no longer have
control over the programs they teach you
cannot teach things that are clearly not
compatible either with the laws of the
Republic or with history as we see it
instead makaan wants to have more imams
trained on French soil there would also
be an end to the hundreds of additional
religious leaders who arrived in France
during Ramadan mosques will be funded in
a transparent way we need to know where
the money is coming from who uses it and
why he said interestingly this echoes a
policy from his political rival marine
lepen during their head-to-head in 2017
her mandate said this
close all extremists mosques identified
by the Minister of the Interior and
prohibit foreign funding of places of
worship and their personnel strong words
coming from the president or is it just
a last-ditch attempt to woo voters ahead
of difficult local elections in just a
few weeks well I think what macro is
trying to do is to shore up his position
with the right-wing electorate but also
with some of the left of course the
question of the lay lay seat of the
secular state in France is important
right across the board and mackerels
relationship with with parties on both
sides of the spectrum will is important
and he needs to make this sort of
statement ahead of municipal elections
voters could be a double-edged sword
france's home to europe's largest muslim
community there are said to be around
six million here that's about 8% of the
population and back in 2017 this
community overwhelmingly voted for
president macron he's already shown that
he's moved away from those centrist
ideologies that he once espoused when he
outlined a tougher stance on immigration
another policy direct from the PlayBook
of lepen so by grasping at ideas that
some see as being from the hard right
wing is he likely to lose voters from
the left and from Muslims there are some
areas of France particularly some local
municipalities some towns and areas
where this is a concern for French
voters and so what macro is doing the
context of it easy is to try to reassure
that where there are large Muslim
communities migrant and Muslim
communities that the Republic is still
there if it's asserting the values of
the secular republic ahead of the
election whether that will succeed or
not remains to be seen you know in the
opinion polls or not don't look like
they're working in in macros favor next
month's elections are seen as being a
referendum on macrons presidency and on
his party on the move could they signal
the beginning of the end
macron ISM salat Dubinsky RT Paris
you